The Joe Rogan Experience and that's how
they've done it throughout history right
I mean that's what they did when they
guy wrote a JFK that's what Liza should
have done with those [__] but those
[__] who turned on her because she
was trying to help them first of all
that that's not even a car like you
don't get to be a fat backup dancer that
doesn't exist it's not real lizzo made
that category of person she made it and
then they turned on her that's crazy
what is she accused of
fat shaming them making them rehearse
making them stand up that's what their
version of fat shaming is making them
stand up and walk onto the stage
making them rehearse taking them to a
sex club in Amsterdam where uh the
performers are shooting uh bananas out
of their [__] because this is what
happens
and lizzo's like forcing him to touch
the nude performers and force one of
them to eat a banana that came out of
the vagina of a sex work a performer
dancer in the sex club lizzo mixed girl
she's like eat the banana eat the banana
and then the girl gets really angry at
that but supposedly
lizzo was just uh abusing her power this
is what they're all saying
but I don't know if I buy that I think
it's bitter people maybe that are
angry
because they all look like lizzo this is
what's going to drive them nuts they
look exactly like her and she's worth 40
million and they're probably getting
paid [__]
so they're in the background every night
dancing and it ain't easy it's fun to be
on that TV show that she had but then
you have to do it every night they're
icing their joints
you know it's hard they're in the
trailer it's [__] tough lizzo had to
start getting on some of them going like
you gotta tone it down you know it's
becoming a problem you know the weight
is becoming a problem and then then
lizzo's response where she's like I
would never fire any of them because of
their weight it's like what a weird
statement they're dancers how [__]
they get
how [__] big can they get if I wanted
to be a dancer for Taylor Swift and she
came up to me and went you're too fat to
do this I'd go that makes sense and I'd
leave with some dignity but these women
lizzo has them on stage she has them
dancing and then all of a sudden you
know she's abusing or making them do
weird [__] and
they all are now suing her and her
streaming has slowed down big time the
ads you know how it is a big uh
cancellation so did she so this show
were these girls dancers before they got
on her show no because girls can't be a
dancer at a certain let's just be very
honest here
they're not at the ballet you know how
the ballerinas are on the tippy toes
that's not happening these women it's a
fetish Dancing Yeah it's a these are
larger women okay and I don't mean like
I oh I had a cheesecake I mean like
these are big big big ladies and they're
dancing because lizzo's whole thing Liz
was like I'm not getting enough
attention just being the fatty up front
I want everyone on stage to be fat so I
can get more praise right because the
media will be like not only is she fat
everyone's fat the whole stage looks
like [__] how good of a person is she
that's what they want I think that's
what she wanted she wanted it wasn't
enough that it was her it had to be
everybody and that's what bitter in the
ass uh but the question is these gals
how often did they have to dance
was it like every night like how often
is that show
was it a once a week show I don't know
but they're on tour so you'd figure when
you're on it they're on tour okay so
they're doing regular shows regular
shows no this is my question when you're
a big girl and you're not exercising
yeah then also someone hires you for a
dance show because they want big girls
right and then you have to do that kind
of [__] every day it's tough your body's
not prepared for that your joints are
weak very hard like you could get really
[__] up doing it's like asking someone
to go into like some crazy
cardiovascular workout right that's it
and they get bad at lizzo because lizard
doesn't have to do anything she just
pulls out the flute can I see what it
looked like can you show me what that
show was like can you show us the big
girls here come the big girls is the
show
but I think they're also angry at lizard
because they're like we're dancing
rehearse and she doesn't have to
rehearse
lizzo just kind of walks out on stage
and sings her songs and does a little
but then pulls out the flute these girls
have to like dance through the whole
thing so it's difficult hard it sounds
hard it's not easy here's the TV show
it's hard for a dancer here we go
okay so there's lizzo it's on Amazon
Prime video
yes lizzo I'm looking for dancers to
join me on my tour girls that look like
me don't get representation time to pull
up my sleeves and find them myself
we think and we pretty and we know but
we doubt it's the battle
of the big girls
with me everything
you could tell how badly this was gonna
go by the way
[Music]
you know why I approach dance
I'm realizing that I do deserve a spot
on that stage it's hard to love yourself
in a world that doesn't love you bad you
were created especially in your image
for you to enjoy you don't have to be
light-skinned you don't have to be
skinny you're just beautiful the way you
are I need to challenge myself and step
outside my comfort zone now I'm going
into competition some people are not at
the same level that I am I'ma call you
lil says he's trying to demean me she's
not understanding how to read the room
get into the show
so what was that one that we just passed
through there was one that like was that
a transgender person yes I believe that
is a transgender person yeah even like a
quick glance yes it was a quick that
wasn't they
I'll say they didn't do a great job at
uh you know fully going to the other
gender there you know what I mean it's
like they kind of stopped and that's
fine not everyone does a great job all
the time and everything about anybody I
brought my car to get washed and it
comes out and you go and that's kind of
what that was
um but that so the show is basically
she's hiring these girls these girls
listen and then they're going on tour
together I've had drug add drug
addictions I've had eating things like
when you are not in a good mental state
which is a lot of the reason people act
out with different things right with
substances with food with whatever you
know and you know listen if you have
people that are emotionally that have
issues you know and lizzo might have
have them as well it's a toxic soup of
maybe that's a becomes a problem on tour
yeah everybody it's the idea of a judge
having to adjudicate this to me is the
funniest thing I've ever the idea of a
judge in a room having to go who called
who fat looking lizards on one side and
then the dance and he's like staring at
everybody going wait who's who who's
what who's fat like it's crazy but you
know it's unfortunate because you know
they're coming for her career yeah
they're coming for her career big time
the show itself seems like it would be a
health risk
oh it is it seems like it would be right
they just force people to work out part
of the lawsuit has to do with the
recording that one of the dancers made
and I'm reading this article this sounds
it's interesting if you guys would want
to read it okay it's pretty fun also
describes an alleged meeting with
dancers on April 27th at which Liza
repeatedly referenced Williams
termination allegedly telling her that
she had quote eyes and ears everywhere
Davis recorded this meeting because she
suffers from an eye condition that can
make her quote disoriented in stressful
situations according to the suit Days
Later lizzo allegedly held an emergency
meeting where she discovered that the
previous meeting had been recorded the
suit says she became Furious hurling
expletives at the group and stating that
she was going to go around the room
present by person until somebody told
lizzo who made the recording according
to the lawsuit the suit says Davis
confirmed that she had recorded the
meeting allegedly told Liz of the Chad
and Anthony harm and I deleted the video
lizzo allegedly responded there is
nothing you can say to make me believe
you so it's kind of like a like Mafia
all right they got well someone did
here's what I want to know when it says
became Furious hurling expletives at the
group and stated that she was going to
go around the room person by person
until someone told lizzo who was making
who made the recording God I hope she
refers to herself in the third turn yes
third person somebody better tell Lizzie
I hope that's how she says that would be
amazing if she said someone better tell
lizzo yeah I mean she brought all these
women on tour probably to abuse them you
know I don't think they thought it
through that's what I'm saying when you
have a bunch of fatty boom baddies yeah
on the tour it's she's probably having a
little fun going girls
you know she's probably ate some [__]
out of banana eat the [__] banana and
also [__] do it cause where else are
you gonna dance right you're not getting
hired anywhere else like unfortunately
or fortunately you're not working right
so you were given this really weird
unique opportunity that only exists with
this one woman yeah it doesn't exist
anywhere else
so you know there's this this is like
not to body shame anybody but there was
there's been a weird shift yes in just
the way society looks at these things
because it used to be that women that
were representing clothes and things had
ideal shapes yes like that's what they
use for advertisements right and then
something changed and they decided Well
Society used to really
prioritize people who could breathe on
their own
and
and I and and listen listen as a person
I've struggled with my weight I but I
know that you give fat is not good
eating the wrong thing isn't good we
shouldn't turn it into good right
there's it's crazy to turn it into good
that's a horrible idea